it's seven o'clock this is drought
emergency a Sky News special program I'm
Mark Austin live at Buell water in Kent
coming up
more than half of England have moved
into drought status after the drier
summer in 50 years
as the waters recede it could mean more
hose pipe bands and tougher local
restrictions
and perhaps more scenes like this the
burnt out shell of a family home
consumed by fire
is the emotional effect and it's a
stress and it's it's also the danger to
human life
we go underground to assess the state of
the country's water supply
and I'm live in Cambridgeshire looking
at the best way to bolster the UK's
water security one possible solution a
giant water pipeline stretching 250
miles but will that be enough
and I'm live on the banks of the river
Rhine in Western Germany as Europe
suffers what could be its worst drought
in 500 years
we report from a Spanish Reservoir now
at its lowest level in almost three
decades
and in Southwest France we witness the
desperate villagers joining firefighters
from across the continent to tackle a
huge wildfire
here in Germany one of Europe's major
waterways down to a critical level with
a potentially devastating impact on
trade
foreign
from what should be the largest stretch
of open water in South East England
Buell water in Kent on the day a drought
was officially declared across more than
half the country
after the drier summer for 50 years here
in Kent a hose pipe ban has just been
introduced and this body of water which
Services much of the county is now at
only 60 percent of its capacity The
Tinderbox conditions are sparking
wildfires here right now fire crews are
dealing with a large Blaze more than 200
miles away from here in Derbyshire with
50 properties evacuated
the fire risk is also high in Europe of
course later in the program we'll report
from Southern France and see firsthand
the economic impact in Germany but we
start in England where the environment
agency has declared a drought in eight
of its 14 areas in Southwest England
Southern and Central England and the
east of England they are Devon and
Cornwall Kent and South London
Hertfordshire and North London East
Anglia Thames Lincolnshire and
northamptonshire the East Midlands the
solent and South Downs from where our
home editor Jason Farrell has our first
report this evening
are once green and pleasant land has
been sapped of color from grass in Hyde
Park yellowed to crop Fields harvested
weeks ahead of schedule due to the heat
the risk of fire is heightened this a
grass fire in Rainham in Essex
Chris Sparks from Hampshire doesn't know
how the fire started in his yard
all right they've spread all through the
roof yeah and then
good God but it had soon devoured a
bedroom wall and then his roof it's like
charcoal is going to rain down on your
living room well yeah because what's
happened is because
it was so hot it was just literally
falling down
the whole house is destroyed Timber
frames charred shoes melted as is the
television
yesterday a tractor caught fire here in
codford in Wiltshire fire risk is
another setback in a difficult summer
for farmers
is the emotional effect and it's the
stress and it's it's also the danger to
to to to human life and uh our staff are
very dedicated and they're very keen to
fight the fires and sometimes we we have
to tell them to ease off a bit because
I'd much rather have a fire than a staff
injury
with some areas of the country not
receiving significant rainfall all
summer the national drought group
declared an official drought in eight of
its 14 areas of the country it means
more hose pipe bands and residents and
businesses being asked to conserve water
the important thing is that the water
supply remains resilient for this year
there's no no real issue there and these
are precautionary steps that are being
taken to ensure that we're taking care
of our water resources in case we get a
dry winter and then run into potential
problems next year people here at the
flower pots Pub in Hampshire say they do
what they can
when you've got a garden you put quite a
lot of money into it and it's all shrubs
and you're sitting there with one
watering can but what I've been using is
old washing up water anything at all is
going into the garden at the moment it's
tough trying to be a bit more
environmentally friendly to see where
the hose pipe band not using water
having showers
I'm not using a bath
in the West Yorkshire penins are usually
submerged Norse Village has partially
reappeared this centuries-old pack horse
bridge now stands as a worrying low
water mark in what should be an abundant
Reservoir
it's just another Oddity in the new
landscape created by this extraordinary
heat wave
Jason Farrell Sky News
drought may have been formally declared
today but some areas have been feeling
the effect for weeks parts of Southwest
England had their driest July in more
than a century but experts say this
isn't just the new normal and in fact it
will get worse Hannah Thomas Peter
reports now on the impact of climate
change and warnings about our future
colliford Lake on bodmin Moore is
cornwall's largest Reservoir
and in this Relentless heat it is drying
up
the receding Waters revealing a
landscape that has been hidden for
decades
you can actually see where the water
levels were around where the black parts
are Cindy Cooper runs a campsite near
the shore she is already feeling the
effects of drought during the peak of
the tourist season people come here for
the views you normally can see out the
windows to the river and at the moment
you can't see any water at all so it's
not very nice for them to come down and
have a look when there's nothing there
to see so it could impact your business
eventually yes
it could
down the road at nine Stones Farm they
are trying to keep the animals cool
Emma Collison is worried about the
dwindling stream that supplies her with
fresh water they have only just
recovered from a TB outbreak here and
can't afford another disaster we've come
out of covert now and and things you we
thought would go back to normal but I
don't think there is a normal anymore
there's just no you know we weren't
expecting this kind of weather and I've
never known anything like it I know I'm
not that old but it's just crazy weather
conditions crazy
in some ways she's right about that
Devon and Cornwall have just experienced
their driest July in over a hundred
years river flows are well below normal
and reservoirs and groundwater sources
are receding and unfortunately there's
no relief in sight no forecast for
significant rainfall where it is
desperately needed
scientists say this is the new reality
of climate change and it's going to get
worse the UK will be seeing more
unprecedented events like we've had
recently hotter drier Summers more
intense heat waves more droughts with
impacts on human health ecosystems
Wildfire risks and so on
a bleak picture of little comfort in
this region now being asked to conserve
water and protect this precious resource
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News at coliford
Lake in Cornwall
well the effects of the extended dry
spell are also being felt in the north
of the country our correspondent inzamam
Rasheed is at a reservoir near Hong
furth in West Yorkshire and in zamama
hose pipe ban already in place there
yeah that's right it will come into
effect in a couple of weeks time mark on
the 26th of August why is that well
Yorkshire a place where you would expect
a lot of rain uh just hasn't simply been
getting it in fact they've got the
lowest levels of rainfall for 130 years
what's that led to it's led to
reservoirs being incredibly lower levels
than they anticipated and then they
expect at this time of the year this
Reservoir behind me has actually been so
low that its natural effects to
um pass water into rivers nearby to keep
the habitat and Wildlife healthy it
hasn't been doing that job they usually
have around 20 liters per second going
into the river nearby to keep that nice
and healthy but instead they've had to
install pumps here to make sure that
other rivers can get that water they are
in fact now going to reduce that that's
because there has been a drought order
in implemented here by the government
which allows Yorkshire water to take
control of the reservoirs and exactly
how they work particularly because of
the hot weather we've been having but
Mark look at this Yorkshire is England's
largest county Yorkshire Water Supplies
5 million customers they'll be facing a
hose pipe ban in two weeks time and
potentially whilst they're not on the
drought list today the environment
agency believed because of this hot
weather because of the lack of rainfall
they could be on that list very soon
okay indomam thanks very much indeed
well the country's reservoirs are not
the only source of water thank goodness
aquifers which are underground layers of
permeable Rock provide up to 70 of
drinking water in some areas but this
valuable resource is also dwindling our
science correspondent Thomas Moore
reports now on the state of the UK's
water supply
yeah
even well beneath the scorched fields of
Somerset there are signs of the drought
work the way down inside the other from
the chamber
we made our way deep into the mendip
hills through swilden's hole
and followed passages carved out by
water over millennia
for the driest summer in 50 years has
reduced the stream to a trickle this is
the mainstream that's flowed from the
surface through the passages and here
it's joined by a tributary called
Rolling Thunder now this water is rain
that has fallen on the soil come through
the Rock
and as you can see it's been so dry
there really isn't much of it
beneath many parts of the country rain
is held in rock like a soaked sponge
overflowing as Springs and also tapped
by water companies for drinking supplies
it's called groundwater and after eight
months of low rainfall levels are
falling so we've got kind of various
factors that will kind of affect the
water that's running down into the cave
in general yeah things are things are
that little bit drier yeah things are a
bit drier than how maybe you would see
them over the past kind of few years or
so in the southern half of England
levels of groundwater are below normal
even exceptionally low in some places
Southern water is keeping a close eye on
the aquifer beneath the South Downs it
pumps out more than 170 liters of
groundwater every second to supply towns
like Brighton we're monitoring it very
very closely you know we'll be be
prepared to react with you know hose
pipe bands or you know things like that
if needs if needs be I think the what's
more concerned for us is that is the
longer term it's the you know it's the
impacts of climate change it's how we're
managing water supply you know for the
next uh for the coming decades if the
sort of weather that we've seen this
summer is going to become the become the
norm
the soil is now so dry that even when
the Autumn rains come it will take weeks
of wet weather before water starts to
refill the underground aquifers this
drought is likely to last even when the
summer heat Fades Thomas More Sky News
in Somerset
let's speak now to Tom Heap the
presenter of Sky's weekly climate show
who is in Cambridgeshire this evening
looking at the possible solutions to
this crisis so Tom help us out here what
is going wrong with water policy in this
country
well I think critics would say that it's
been too focused on if you like just in
time water delivery and keeping the
bills very low as opposed to making a
resilient long-term water supply network
especially in the face of climate change
and one of the areas that's particularly
been paying for that is our natural
environment many of the water companies
have been pulling a lot of water out of
the Rocks beneath them if you just heard
from from Thomas Moore there and the
effect has on that of that has been
rivers in serious trouble not just this
year where incidentally we've got six
Rivers at least that are at record low
levels spreading from the Rother up in
Yorkshire to the Tain in the west
country to the wave near across here in
Suffolk but that has been a problem for
quite a few years for many rivers and
the impact of that on Wildlife well I
can show you a little bit here from the
this is comes from the dry bed of this
Reservoir I know if you can see there
are tiny muscles on here well these are
you know completely lifeless dry as dust
as a result of low water so that's the
kind of effect that low water can have
on our natural world and there has been
a feeling that policy has put the burden
on the natural world and we now may be
feeling that as well as we look forward
with all these challenges from climate
change that Hannah Thomas Peter was
talking about earlier
so how do things get fixed here then
well probably with a lot of political
concentration and quite a lot of money
so the ideas that are required need a
lot of infrastructure a lot of concrete
a lot of digging in a lot of machines
we've been to look at a project where
they're pulling water down from the
Humber through massive pipes like this
capable of Shifting 84 million liters a
day down to this area East only all the
way as far as Colchester 250 miles in
total now that scheme alone costs about
half a billion pounds but they say that
won't be enough in the long term we will
need to think about digging more
reservoirs and just later this year
probably in the Autumn a lot of projects
four across the southeast that's two in
East Anglia one in the Thames water area
and one in Hampshire water projects for
new reservoirs are going to be given
real consideration by the government
they're going out to consultation which
is a key stage in them actually
happening but they'd probably take at
least two decades there about to come
into reality
but a lot of people listening to this
Tom will be saying what's going on we're
a we're a wet country We're a nation of
rainfall
well this is very true I mean the the
cameraman James is give me an umbrella
which he keeps in his van to keep the
rain off presenters well it's becoming
in very handy to keep it off me today
you know that's what people imagine
we're black umbrellas we're soggy
glastonburys we're wet wimbledon's but
the truth is in many parts especially of
the southeast we actually get less
rainfall per head than many many really
really hot countries that you would
associate with being dry so there's a
question about whether we need to change
our Behavior do we need to think about
shorter showers turning that tap off
when you're brushing your teeth maybe
even fitting a little infrastructure
into our homes like rain water
Harvesters or things that capture your
bath water and maybe put that on the
garden rather than using a hose full of
pristine drinking water and even maybe
do you need to flush the loop every time
you go for a week these are the kind of
things that maybe we need to be thinking
because we used to use around 80 we used
to use around 80 liters a person of
water person per day that's gone up to
around 130 and there are more of us in
the Southeast big questions
yeah a few realities to think about Tom
thank you very much indeed
well welcome to koblenz in Western
Germany we're on the banks of the Ryan
River one of Europe's busiest and of
course most important waterways but the
water levels here have reached
critically low points in the last few
days 40 centimeters today making the
river impossible for many cargo ships
transporting goods like coal and petrol
and this is a crucial trade route almost
half of the European Union is now under
an official drought warning with
officials suggesting that this could be
Europe's worst drought in 500 years well
let's take a look at those water
warnings across the continent 63 percent
of land is under an alert or warning
state of drought and severely drier than
normal weather is now predicted until
the end of the summer
here on the river Rhine water levels
have fallen to below the critical 40
centimeter Mark making it virtually
impossible for many barges
but later on we'll hear from our
correspondent in the south of France
where more than 1 500 firefighters are
struggling to contain a major Wildfire
but first to Spain where the hottest
July in over 60 years has resulted in
the key finuela Reservoir dropping to
just 12 of capacity from there a special
correspondent Alex Crawford reports on
the crisis in Spain
hard to believe this is the bed of one
of the largest reservoirs in southern
Spain this Jetty was floating and the
pedal Boats were being used right at
this spot less than a year ago but now
parts of the Venezuela Reservoir are
bone dry and getting drier and it's
operating at only around 12 percent of
its capacity look at the state of this
Earth the cracks are so deep the levels
are dropping at a terrifying rate all of
this was once underwater and the
environmentalists say it's not just
climate change that's a problem it's
water mismanagement and Farmers
switching to crops which demand much
more water
whatever the reason the record high
temperatures have led to fractured
relations here and what's being dubbed
the water wars as farmers and
environmentalists squabble over who and
what's caused this
are some of the Exotic fruits being
blamed for the water drain
many farmers like Paco have branched out
into growing mangoes and avocados
he's telling us here how efficient his
irrigation system is but the drought has
meant his mangoes are still
significantly smaller and his income has
dropped nearly a quarter over the past
few years
the lack of water fires everything it's
all down to climate change and we're all
causing climate change so we have to
change
he's built his own Reservoir and is
investigating growing less thirsty
fruits like Barbary figs but all the
farms around here are suffering under
these extreme conditions
yeah a colleges in the area say poor
farming and lack of planning by the
authorities are responsible
there's already a problem because too
many farmers are using irrigation and we
have to stop that and persuade them to
find Alternatives like recycling water
and grow in other fruits
autumn
with Farms working all hours to try to
save their crops
maroon boys show just how tourism is
already suffering around the reservoir
Eleanor Sanchez was left with no option
but to close down her water adventure
business
there's water here yes
he's worried a farming of tropical
fruits like avocados and mangoes
collapses it'll have a devastating
impact
the tropical industry it brings about 10
000 Employments to this area so what are
these people going to work in if we
don't have tropicals
Spain produces the bulk of Europe's
fruit and vegetables this country's
Water Crisis is going to reach far
beyond its own borders
Alex Crawford Sky News in southern Spain
well from Spain to France which is
experiencing its worst ever drought 100
towns have completely run out of water
and firefighters from across Europe
Germany Poland and Romania and Italy
have been drafted in to help tackle a
wildfire near gerund in Bordeaux and
that's forced the evacuation of around 8
000 homes Sky's Laura bundock reports
now on a wildfire that has been burning
for more than a month
wild fires swept through here and left a
haunting site the Flames are gone but
look at the smoldering soil
I'm firefighter still 26 years and I
never knew that situation
fire chief Stephanie Marta says drought
and Heatwave are a deadly combination
when it's dry weather all the water in
the vegetables are just going out when
the fire arrives it's just
um
easier because all the trees have less
defense to fight against the fire
the wildfires in gerund have been
burning for weeks they're battling
around the clock on the ground and from
the air
[Applause]
Dean hundred firefighters here from all
over Europe
and closer to home we found Village
Vigilantes local volunteers carrying and
doing what they can
um
oh but they all agree they won't give up
it feels Relentless this is the problem
walk anywhere in the forest and you'll
find these pockets of smoke the peat
soil here is now so hot you can actually
feel the heat rising up from the ground
below
it is truly terrifying for people here
they desperately need rain but can only
hope it comes soon
well Laura joins us now live from girond
and Laura perhaps no surprise you know
you're talking about the fear for the
people living there that so many local
people are are physically helping the
firefighters out
I think they've little Choice Jane but
to get involved such as the scale of the
problem and the emergency here the
weather is making things so much harder
it is hot and it is really dry the
conditions are difficult and they're
dangerous and today the real fear has
been flare-ups within the forest because
the ground is smoldering just take a
look over to the side here you can see a
classic example a patch of smoke there
rising up from the soil and we're seeing
this everywhere we go at the moment
there were fires here back in July all
those fires obviously have been put out
now but the ground itself has stayed so
hot you see these patches of smoke
rising up and the problem is they catch
onto the Tinder dry ground here and
that's when the fires restart and today
the real problem has been the Heat this
intense heat the hottest day of this
current Heat Wave we're told
temperatures over 40 degrees which is
why the firefighters told us it's a
critical day we were out with them this
morning and we saw what they're doing to
to try and bring these fires under
control huge fire breaks being dug
damping down dousing the land but it
feels never ending as soon as one fire
is put out another one pops up elsewhere
and the trouble is the drought they
haven't had rain here for over a month
it's what they really need although it's
forecast on on Sunday one firefighter
told me a day's rain won't be nearly
enough they need at least two weeks of
solid rain if these wildfires are to be
brought under control
don't worry it sounds absolutely
terrifying thanks very much well where
we are is where the river Rhine and the
rivermosel meets and last summer this
area here was devastated by floods there
were more than 100 people killed here
and if we we get the camera to pan over
where I'm standing is would have been
deep deep within the river of rhyme the
water was up to the tops of where those
Caravans are in that campsite behind us
so that just shows you the extraordinary
difference in the water levels it would
have been way way over my head and it
would normally be way over my head of 12
months on the weeks of dry weather have
seen the water levels now falling to
really critical levels here there is a
real fear that the Rhine could have to
be closed to many of the larger cargo
ships and I've been talking to people in
this region about the economic impact
that the drought is having on them
the Rhine is shrinking shrinking so much
it now has a beach
Germany's commercial artery carries
every cargo imaginable steel fuel
chemicals as far as the North Sea but at
the busy Port Town of koblenz the barges
are now leaving three quarters empty
on the wall there are different colors
and that's a normal water level now it's
decreased very much they need more ships
for the same cargo that means the ships
are more expensive and um
the costs per ton are increasing
the pinch point is reached Downstream at
Kalb some large barges can no longer
pass here
this isn't the bank of the river Rhine
that I'm standing on it's the bed of the
river Rhine so much has the water
receded over the last couple of months
because of the lack of rainfall and the
ships that you can see passing behind me
would normally have about two meters of
water beneath them so that that's about
that much water but at the minute some
parts have got as little as this much
water 40 centimeters below the boats as
they pass
and the land the Rhine ribbons through
is equally parched for 30 years reinhoit
herner has watched his Vineyard slowly
desiccate he's noticed the insects and
the weeds changing he last Saw rain on
June the 6th
is
West Side this is
the steps that they are taking to try to
combat the hot weather on this Vineyard
are quite extraordinary they're pumping
30 000 liters of water onto these young
Vines every single day they're also
allowing the leaves to grow bigger and
to shelter The Grapes below they've got
two planes and two pilots on standby for
the whole of the summer in case there
should be a hail storm which would
damage the grapes it's not just the wine
harvested threat his neighbors have lost
a third of their corn it's just stopped
growing
of course we know that in any language
the Rhine May for now still be teeming
with life but many Germans are
questioning for how much longer they
will be able to rely upon it as an
economic lifeline
we saw those fish at the end of that
report but the Rhine is still fine for
fish but there are rivers in France that
we've heard of where fish are dying
because as the rivers shrink the amount
of space the fish have shrinks and the
oxygen shrinks with it I mean the Rhine
is not as you heard in my report just a
river it's a vital artery and and if you
look at where we are now there's a
massive Fort over this Confluence of the
two rivers this is a river that has been
fought over for years so key is it to
Germany's economy and along the stretch
of the river Ryan it is
there are Vineyards there are castles
all the way along the side of of this
River and the people that we've spoken
to over the last couple of days are
really acknowledging that there is a
change happening to this River it is
getting smaller the land around it is
getting drier I think they sense the
change is coming and that if anything
can be done that they have to change
with it and all the people that we have
spoken to here say they firmly believe
that what is happening here to this
River and to the land around it is a
direct result of climate change
yeah really quite alarming Jane thanks
very much indeed well back here today's
drought announcement we'll see the
environment agency and water companies
across the affected areas implementing
their plans to manage falling water
levels those plans will more than likely
include more restrictions here in Kent a
hose pipe ban was introduced today as
Iva Bennett reports
it is the garden of England but how can
anything bloom in this The Village
greens of Kent haven't been that color
for weeks what we put in here is a
gravel Garden Roger field helps to
maintain the flower beds in the village
of lye with his wife Joyce but even
before this hose pipe ban they were
already resigned to losing them it
wouldn't be a tragedy as such but it
would be a shame and it would be
um another sort of nail in the coffin of
a village life I can't remember last
time now when we really what I call
really had
I don't remember
and for those who rely on the green
fingered here things are now even harder
as a business this Garden Center outside
Tunbridge is exempt from the
restrictions but its customers aren't
and having seen sales carve over the
summer they fear they'll drive even
further it is a quiet time but it's
really quiet right now because putting a
plant into the ground today
is a challenge I mean physically getting
out in the garden you've got to be
conscious of sunburn and all those
things as well so it is having a huge
impact across garden centers and British
nurseries throughout the country anyone
who breaks the hose pipe ban could be
fined up to a thousand pounds but it
seems there are few here willing to do
as Southeast water asks and grass up any
neighbors breaking the rules will you be
snitching on any neighbors no well no
I wouldn't go out my way to grow someone
in I've just come through a traffic jam
that's got a burst pipe going running
down the road and there's nobody working
on it so you sort of think to yourself
it's very important in The Lakes as
unprecedented as these conditions are
people here know they may have to get
used to them but that means not just
reducing how much water we use there's
also a real need for us as a society to
improve how water is collected and
stored for the future
but when pushed by Sky News water
regulator off what refused to pin blame
on providers despite three billion
liters lost through leakage every day
Nationwide what we're doing and seeing
on demand reduction and what we're
seeing on leakage reduction needs to go
a lot further we absolutely accept that
with the target for the sector has
reduced leaks by 50. we recognize there
has been a failure no what I recognize
is there's quite a long way to go
and so for now the onus is on households
to maintain Water Supplies no wonder
then some are seeking out the few
natural sources that remain
either Bennett Sky News in Kent
well this year's drought has been caused
by seven months of unusually dry weather
earlier we sent our science
correspondent Thomas Moore deep
underground but he's also been assessing
the drop in rainfall across the country
what a difference a year makes these are
satellite images for July this year and
12 months ago England's Green Pastures
turned brown met off his stats show
Southern England had just 10 millimeters
of rain in July the driest in records
back to 1836 before even Queen Victoria
was on the throne so how does the
current situation compare to 1976 an
exceptional drought year when people got
their water from Stand pipes our map
shows that July's rainfall in the
Southeast corner of the country this
year has been well below the levels of
1976. what about the year so far after
all droughts are the result of months of
dry weather well let's look at Kent
where the cumulative rainfall total for
2022 is well below the long term average
but so far it's still higher than 1976.
now of course temperatures this summer
have been much higher and that's left
the landscape parched latest data from
the environment agency shows the soil in
Devon and Cornwall is close to its
driest ever for the time of year
River levels at the end of July were
also exceptionally low in many parts of
the country the Thames in Windsor had
the lowest flow on record so did the
crane Brent and ingerbourne in London
and in East Anglia the wave knee little
ooze and Eli ooze where water was just
five percent of the long-term average
levels in the underground aquifers that
Supply water to millions of people are
also falling in many areas they're
exceptionally low in monitoring sites in
the Cotswolds and the South Downs and
Reservoir levels are falling fast as
demand for water has soared arding lie
in Sussex and the lower Thames
reservoirs have never been lower than
this at this time of year much of
England is short of water and with
August expected to be dry in the South
it is only going to get worse
foreign
conditions of course bring with them a
greater threat of fire we've seen a
grass fire in Raynham in Essex today
with the chair of National Fire Chiefs
Council saying soaring temperatures are
making incidents harder to manage and
harder to put out meanwhile the national
Farmers Union says Tinder dry crops and
parched grass pose a huge danger Chief
north of England correspondent Greg
Milam reports now on the growing fire
risk
high up on the Moors the Wildfire
Specialists from West Yorkshire fire
service are on high alert increasingly
hot dry weather has created the perfect
conditions for fires up here and the way
they deal with them has had to evolve
they now use these off-road vehicles
that can reach fires regular engines
can't in terrain like this
location is massive up here because
you've no water so we've only got a
limited amount of water so we have to
have water to deal with the fire but
then we've also got to have a backup
plan and it doesn't take much to start a
fire the message to the public is just
you know be very Mindful and careful of
what you do in in this beautiful
countryside we are on top of the mall
now and the wind is blustery this grass
is very very dry and it wasn't that long
ago that a fire swept up the hillside
over there and came perilously close to
this transmitter which would have wiped
out Communications across a huge area
it's another illustration of how these
wildfires are potentially affecting
people Way Beyond just the countryside
the fires on the Moors this summer have
spread to areas not usually affected and
fires like this in a cornfield once rare
have also become more common for the
fire service the causes and the need to
change is unmistakable we've seen the
effects of climate change developing but
what we've just seen is radically
different a completely different end of
a Continuum and if that's a peep into
the future then I think we better go
back and we've got to look at everything
we've done to date and just reassess
about whether that's what we need going
forward or whether we need to do even
more and I think that applies to society
as well it's been a quiet couple of days
for the Wildfire team but with more
people out on a hot weekend they know
that's unlikely to last Greg Milam Sky
News West Yorkshire
well I should just tell you that in the
last hour a major incident has been
declared in Derbyshire where 12 fire
crews are dealing with a fire in fields
and around a farm are 50 properties in
that area have been evacuated in
Creswell with local residents gathering
at uh the villages Events Center that
fire in Derbyshire
so across this desperately dry land the
inevitable has now happened and much of
the country is now officially under
drought restrictions as we enter another
weekend of baking temperatures millions
of people in this country are now being
asked to change the way they live in
terms of water usage how long it will
last no one knows that depends on the
weather on nature and what it has in
store for us we leave you now with a
look at how this summer of unrelenting
heat has changed the face of Britain
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign